this is actually a viewer question uh
how did it feel when he first got
published
i enjoyed it pretty well oh
uh i am signing warbreaker tonight
i'm sorry uh brandon keeps zoom bombing
me brandon you know it's coming yeah
you've been doing this all week
what this is so weird brandon can you
please try to stay quiet while i finish
talking to mr rothfuss
i don't think i have the acting skill
don't don't i'm telling a story right
now and that means everyone has to pay
attention to me because i'm
cool i doubt it patrick you're doing
fine all right he's just clearly jealous
of your beard
you just cheated are you saying his
beard is fake
i don't even know if that like i said is
a real thing can i please get back
to our interview we are done now here's
what's coming next
okay now brandon's just streaming old
copyrighted football games all right
it might be in violation of the twitch
terms of service well this will be on
youtube but yeah i
i see what you mean look i'm just gonna
end this call all right all joking aside
did you know that elon musk followed me
on twitter
yeah this is done this is done
you